There are three major idol groups with the largest number of fans in Korea.
First up is TVXQ.
With approximately 600,000 official fans,...
...TVXQ's fan club made it to the Guinness Book of World Records in 2008...
...as being the world's largest.
Next are the BIGBANG fans.
BIGBANG boasts over 280,000 fans around the world.
True to their very individualistic styles,...
...fans of BIGBANG are known to cater to the boys every woman fancy.
Last but not least, they are the Girls' Generation fans.
Girls' Generation is the top girl group in Korea with over 240,000 official fans.
They have the largest fan club out of all the K-pop girl groups.
All their singles have hit number 1 on the Korean music charts,...
...as well as making it to the top of overseas music charts.